having a house the hombres my
experiments ripped games I found a
couple awesome months first one is
sagging cervix alright thank you stop
get away from me stop following me
oh god this rings man gotta get them all
all right this is why he'd be standing
goes so fast to escape all these
attractions all right I'll see you later
then
Oh Oh Mamma Mia I feel like those are
gonna pop if I come near them I've seen
it out goddamn it what do you have to
[ __ ] off will ya oh it does doesn't it
Wow nice nap pulse if you get what I'm
saying knock oh god oh god get off my
face oh it's a sanic 'mobile you're
right
no I Oh gentles Oh God
Missy want a hug or do you want to
squeeze my name's is worth the chance
alright [ __ ] off what do you I love you
wow that's a cool static right there you
want to hear something yes holy [ __ ]
you're not kidding are you
okay I'm look at that guy that guy is
cooler than cool I've seen hell I see
the hell this is it Oh God must escape
somehow please yes I'm free I'm [ __ ]
free please let me out of here oh god
let me go please let me go
maybe if I collect all the Rings
[Music]
what the friggin true I'm free
Oh God anymore no I thought I was gonna
go all right I'm gonna going I'm going
sorry sorry oh this is probably my
favorite Sonic
oh god sonic what are you doing don't
decompose static stay strong and don't
decompose Oh God
hey Robotnik how you doing yeah that's
me
oh you're cute I know you're free sanic
one of the others warn the king then
come back and save me thank god they're
still after me that was amazing I would
write this the best rating out of all
ratings next up we have South Park
coming to VR which is pretty cool it
looks like a cool project so I'm excited
about this one oh my god this is so cool
guys oh my god nice to happen it see me
you guys waiting for the bus this is so
awesome
okay well I guess it
oh look at that basic oh my god it's
just so weird this is so cool I wish
that but a stick of truth was like this
it would have been amazing
ah oh the cure you what are you doing
all right
this is pretty awesome I'm really
kidding soon what this is gonna be the
future but that's very cool very very
cool next game it's not an oculus game
but it has their hydros so I thought
it'd be cool to check out it's cold tofu
Ali and I have pretty small Bank oh god
I miss oh there you go [ __ ] off so for
this is my alleyway that's right
stop it tofu please oh yes karate
protection ok but [ __ ] me alright I got
this one [ __ ] to talk about a phone
you want some of this
BAM that's right tofu you don't [ __ ]
with me now damn it I'm so bad at this
[ __ ] off' oh man [ __ ] you [ __ ] bucka
phone
let's try another one ok I'm so far away
I even realized all right this game I'm
really excited about
it looks amazing so you basically like
spider oh god this game is so nice and
so calm it looks beautiful
oh god I'm so fast in my sanic oh god oh
god where from did I shoot that oh god
this is the most disgusting game I have
ever seen I am shooting this for my junk
it looks like it at least that's amazing
oh god this is so cool and I'm not
merchants sake what the [ __ ]
oh so it only speaks to certain type of
surfaces let's go here then what ah la
la la come on man
yeah yeah you said sperms yeah I wish
that's more like a dangling effect to it
you know I kind of feel like I'm [ __ ]
alright I had a good life see it's
really up to the developer if the game
will be causing motion sickness or night
kiss even though I'm jumping around like
a maniac I feel like I'm the one
controlling it oh yes I got it oh my god
I am Superman Batman and spider-man I'm
swimming I always wanted to jump on
giant green disco balls ah it's really
hard to come on [ __ ] yes [ __ ] what am
I I'm sperm man that's what I am I'm
gonna king of the world that's what a
[ __ ] am so amazing let's do a super
young
come on let me say mang never thought
I'd say that [ __ ] next up its the
virtual reality opera I don't know what
that is I'm bad well you gotta check it
out it's called cents up peso all right
hi I'm Brady bring it on then bring the
show on well well beautiful am I going
in there I don't go in there I look
dangerous
I'm gonna sit in my chair all right just
raise yes
[ __ ] yeah I can just smell the music
flowing through my body
[Music]
I
okay then
[Music]
are you lost man no all right then how
it applies approach all right man you're
really close aren't you
oh I'm really weirded out by this what
this don't that's close enough sir let's
close it out thank you I I'm all right
I'm so sorry
Oh
where are we going Gary take me home
take my yes throw the light I've got my
boots I didn't say that hey that's
awesome that was a couple of different
virtual reality games
long story short VR is awesome and it's
really fun for me to check out these
games for you bros and I'll leave them
all in the description as always go
ahead and leave a like if you enjoy
watching everything preciate it it helps
me out a lot and it makes it feel better
about your days in jail what are you
doing in jail that's good okay Ralph's
ass